now the International Monetary Fund says
global growth will be the strongest
since 2011 at three point nine percent
both this year and next but there are
concerns not least potential barriers to
trade from the United States China and
elsewhere there was a slight upgrade for
UK growth to 1.6 percent this year
meanwhile China's announced its growth
during the last quarter was 6.8 percent
which is of course above its
six-and-a-half percent target with
earlier I spoke to the incoming
secretary-general of the world's biggest
business organization the International
Chambers of Commerce
I asked John Denton for his view on the
outlook for the global economy when I
look at the state of the world economy
and I almost repeat what Christine
Lagarde is saying I mean the sun is
shining there's a there's an upswing
going on and it's very very positive the
challenges we see how do we maintain
that momentum and what we don't want to
see as distractions to that and we don't
see inward policy formation which will
actually undermine the prospects for
growth and obviously for sustained
economic growth it's not just capital
it's not just productivity but it's also
about technological transformation and
we want to see economies focus much more
on that aspect ensuring that that's the
source of their economic growth and
that's there's some issues that need to
be fleshed out through the WTO which
actually the only organization that can
live deliver up global norms that will
enable the continued growth of digital
platform and also the continued growth
of access to ecommerce and things like
that which is very important for SMEs
and micro SM is but how worried are you
about this apparent kickback against
globalization the fats that in some
Western nations including the UK the
United States people seem now to be
positively against free movement of
capital and labour yeah well I think the
word very uncertain times and I but I
don't think this issue this issue or
this this tone of the times must be
permanent I think we have to recognize a
couple of things that firstly probably
the two critical assumptions upon which
this unbounded global growth that we saw
in the 2000s were based probably
over-promised and the first was that
global trade would actually on the
aggregate create greater wealth for all
but the reality is that's not how it
played out and the second that by
letting a number of developing
countries participate in the kind of
global trading system that they would
continue to open up the borders reduce
tariffs and move away from non-tariff
barriers uh behind the border
restrictions both of these assumptions
proved a little over optimistic but I
think some of these systemically
important and not quite open economies
need to do some reform and I include
China in there and I include India and
now these are systemically important
economies that are benefitting from the
open trading system but they actually do
need to do more in terms of reform
particular in terms of opening up the
economy economies and this is not
necessarily only in tariffs but in non
tech non-tariff barriers as well so
enabling investment be much clearer
about those sorts of issues but it
sounds from what you're saying the need
for some of these big systemically
important countries to open up that you
have some sympathy with Donald Trump in
terms of some of the things that he's
saying about China but but the reality
is not everything that Donald Trump says
is wrong it's easier for a Chinese to
invest in Australia than for Australians
to invest in China and ditto with
America so it's not just about the trade
deficit there is no doubt and China
recognizes itself that it needs to open
up more parts of its economy there is no
doubt in China noses itself that some of
the points that America has made are not
misplaced the challenge for them is how
they actually make that work in their
own domestic economy what do you make of
the sanctions at America and some of its
allies have just introduced against
Russia is that not going to push Russia
back into a more isolationist position
we need to have people abide by the
rules we need to have people know that
if they break the rules there are
consequences and in the global security
of global political arena the kind of
consequences must be more than just
shaming there actually needs to be some
form of security sanction and actually
denial of access to the US financial
services system that your financial
system seems to be one of the most
powerful tools that's available at the
moment it should however only be used
very sparingly and it is a real problem
and unfortunately the capacity of global
leaders to engage in constructive
discussions to lessen tension
seems to be sad sadly missing at the
moment what we're seeing is exacerbated
tensions not just with Russia but also
with China